Hello Freak bitches.
I mean,
obviously the Western world
has plenty of problems,
but one thing the western world has
pretty clearly is the even exchange of
information and ideas.
You might not agree with these ideas
and you might meet and then that's it.
There's a problem with that as well.
But,
but you have access to them,
you have access to them.
And this access is like,
well,
that's one of the things
that's going on with Twitter.
And I don't know if you know about this,
but Milo Yiannopoulos,
you know what he is?
He got banned from Twitter for writing
a bad review about Ghostbusters,
which essentially confirms what he
said about the regressive left is that
they're trying to stifle ideas like
w and then they're saying that he's
responsible for the
harassment of Leslie Jones.
Right.
Which is horrible.
You know what people did?
She's a fucking comedian.
She's awesome.
Great.
She's great.
She's funny shit,
man.
Um,
but also this is just trolls.
All right.
You're always going to have trolls.
But he didn't do that.
He didn't,
he's not responsible for,
he didn't like sin.
He wasn't the catalyst to the,
yeah,
but what he did was make an incredible
amount of sense when he was describing
that you cannot make fun of this movie.
You cannot criticize this movie if you do,
you're labeled a massage.
And he talked about how preposterous this
movie is that these women are all out
kicking ass and every man,
the movie's a buffoon and the women don't
have any negative traits or qualities
at all.
They're there.
They're super powerful and
super awesome and hilarious.
And the,
the humor is nonexistent because they
put them in this restrictive box.
He got banned from Twitter for that band,
for Twitter,
for this you what they are.
They're blaming him on the harassment
that Leslie experience inside of the
inside anything.
He made a provocative article about a
piece of art and that's what that movie is
a piece of art.
So they are,
they are guilty of censorship in the,
in the worst way.
Well,
what they're doing is they're stifling
ideas they don't agree with and they've,
they've decided that Twitter establish
some weird fucking thing called the trust
and Security Council
or something like that.
And they brought all these
social dressed justice worse.
Jamie looked that up.
What the fuck is that call
that they tried to do?
But they brought on all
these people for this.
I was like,
Mao's China,
but Jesus Christ,
very,
very bizarre troll.
It is thought patrol.
Well,
look,
I'm against harassment.
If you could stop people from
being shitty to people and you say,
well,
here's someone who's using Twitter and
they're going after people in a very
shitty way.
But the problem with that is look at how
many fucking people have made shitty,
horrible,
evil comments about police officers,
all police officers,
trust and safety council.
When it comes to safety,
everyone plays a role.
Please make that larger so I can read it.
Which one are your powers?
Twitter empowers every
voice to shape the world,
but you can't do that unless you feel
safe and confident enough to express
yourself freely and connect with the
world around you to help give your voice
more power.
Twitter does not behavior
intended to harass,
intimidate,
or use fear to silence
another user's voice.
Very general,
by the way.
So now you have a council that is deciding
whether or not you're good enough for
Twitter as well.
You know what the first
thing they did with him,
they couldn't figure
out what to do with him.
They took away his verification.
Wow.
What?
What does that have to do with,
wow,
what does that,
he's not verified anymore.
They took away a little blue chat.
Yeah,
it's very dangerous.
It's a very dangerous,
slippery slope.
But we see the scenario universities,
you do exactly the same thing.
When they did that,
he gained 20,000 new followers immediately
because there was a massive backlash.
So now they're in a place where
there is even more backlash.
Cause if you look at the actual words
that he typed versus what they're accusing
him of and it just doesn't stack up,
it's clear that they don't like
him because he's a Republican.
He's a Trump supporter.
He and he is a fucking troll.
I love him.
I think he's hilarious.
He's a troll.
But in the marketplace of ideas,
you should be able to combat
his trolling behavior,
gag without gagging,
gagging and engage him,
engage him.
In a debate and a vigorous spirit.
Exactly.
Gag The guy.
Right.
If you really feel like he
has done something egregious,
if he's done something
that can be criticized,
criticized it.
That's right.
And if he's actually harassing people,
if he's actually saying,
Hey,
go find Leslie Jones and,
and throw dog shit out,
or do something horrible to her or
slash your tires or something like that,
he's actually doing something like that.
Yeah.
Then you know,
then he's doing this.
That's where that you don't get up in
a crowded movie theater and scream fire
because you'll create a stampede.
Yeah.
Right.
Exactly.
You know my Angela talked about that when
she said where the Ku Ku Klux Klan was
saying,
we have a freedom of speech,
and my Angela said,
you're a freedom ends.
Your freedom of speech can end when
you're literally telling people to hang me
and you're telling a mob and I'm standing
right there that the inciting them,
that's,
that's probably where you know,
we should take a look at
things and we all know,
we all know the line.
We don't know about what,
no,
I'm saying,
I'm saying that that there is something
called common decency and you know,
people like to jump to these extremes,
but it's not,
it doesn't inform the debate.
I think what you're
saying is so important.
And then the idea that you've got to
create safe haven for those that you agree
with and disagree with.
Disagree with Milo all the time.
Yeah.
I mean he and I are friends and I've
had him on the podcast twice and when we
talk,
I'm mock them when we have fun.
I mean,
but he's a good guy,
but he's just really right wing.
I also think his trolling is so fucking
sophisticated and he's one of the ones
that was saying that he
believes that Melania,
how do you say her name?
Trump.
Melania.
Is that her name?
Yeah,
he thinks that they did it on purpose.
He thinks Trump is a master troll and
he thinks that the plagiarism was on
purpose because now more people are
talking about it and then more people are,
I don't know if that's true,
but I think it's hilarious that
you did you know that his tweet,
Trump's tweet that he put
out to congratulate his
wife for speaking is exactly
verbatim the same tweet that Obama
put out to congratulate his wife for
speaking.
Interesting.
Exactly.
Every single word in the exact same order.
Wow.
Yes.
Oh,
that's pretty calculated.
I don't know.
I don't think he writes his own tweets.
That apparently wasn't true.
Is it fake like that
was like photoshopped.
Oh,
this fuckers they got me.
That was the other thing they did.
I'm sorry about that folks.
That's another thing that they
did with the Leslie Jones,
which she was really upset,
is that trolls were taking words and
putting them like they were taking a
Photoshop and making her like her name,
like what she had heard her Twitter name
and then writing horrible shit about
gay people and then putting it in there.
Jesus.
But Leslie Jones and again,
I love her.
I think she's really funny.
She said some kind of fucked up things on,
on Twitter herself and you know,
things that can be construed as racist.
One of the things she said like about
white people being shit fuck white people.
Shit.
Like something like that.
It was a on on Breitbart.
See if you could,
you'd find the actual,
uh,
things that they were,
there were saying that like,
how could Leslie Jones
get away with saying this?
But Milo gets banned for writing
an article and I'm not you ma'am.
But I think what Leslie said,
like white people,
Shit,
it could've been that she was saying like,
someone did something
and Goddamn white people,
this is some white people.
Shit.
Yeah.
You know,
like,
she's funny.
Like when people climb into a zoo
and try to fucking hug a tiger,
that's why people,
that's why people shit.
That's funny though.
And Laissez anybody who
knows me knows she's great.
She's just that fucking Dall
Lord have mercy white people.
Shit.
What does that mean though?
It's white people shit.
They crazy style.
I mean,
what does that mean?
Like why did she say that?
Like what does that about
who imagine a white person,
but look at this,
imagine a white person saying
that about black people.
I understand,
but I think I,
you know,
we've heard this before and we,
it's fine.
Leslie Jones is not a
racist and Leslie Jones's,
it never been anything but
really kind to people around her.
Okay.
But hold on a second because sometimes
people say things that are racist and
they're not racist.
They're just trying to be funny.
Yes.
Like you know,
I mean Hawaii 2 cents and if sometimes it,
Jeff Ross is hilarious and he says a
lot of racial stuff when he deserves
Silberman Bowl,
Sarah Silverman.
But if Jeff Ross in particular,
because he's really good at
roasting people and a lot
of the stuff that he says,
like,
you know,
he crosses what some
people would say is a line,
but what is he doing?
He's being funny.
There is,
there is a difference.
So a lot of times if you're Hispanic,
um,
if you're,
you know,
you're from a marginalized group,
you can get away with it because you,
you all share in a common
experience of repression.
Right?
So like gay people can
mock straight people guide,
go ahead.
Mock me for liking Posey.
Who Cares?
That's what I mean.
Cause we don't,
we've never had to pay a price
for that kind of oppression.
We haven't,
not physically and not,
not economically issue because we've been
oppressed for being straight forever.
It's a constant thing.
People were just so mad that we're
saying breeder fucking breeder,
they're making babies.
Okay.